hello hello my name is linda and i am
here to talk about software for court
appointed special advocates for foster
youth
and here is the twitter and
the slack and the email who uses email
[Music]
who am i i've been a developer since
2010 i started my career at thoughtworks
which is a consultancy i've worked in a
variety of industries including airlines
and payment processing
and now i work in health tech i work in
health tech because i figured out what i
want to do with the rest of my life
which by the way is terrifying
um i plan to spend the rest of my
foreseeable future taking my revenge
upon the usa healthcare system by trying
to improve it heck yes
[Applause]
shout out to my open source supportive
employer parachute health
they help patients get their prescribed
durable medical equipment like
wheelchairs and cpaps attempting to
replace some fax machines somewhere
working on it we are hiring talk to me
and i have been a lead of the casa
project since it started in 2019.
some quick definitions because we do
have namespace collisions
casa is a non-profit which trains
volunteers to help foster youth ruby for
good is a non-profit which builds
software for other nonprofits
ruby for good casa project is software
written by ruby for good to help casa
this talk is about this one particular
project
and specifically creating an ecosystem
for writing open source software
specifically software as a service open
source software which serves volunteers
who serve foster youth
foster youth
raise your hand if
321 audience participation you have ever
thought about the usa foster care system
ever had it cross your mind
rock on all right you can put your hands
down
a lot of people have a lot of people
know somebody or work somewhere or
volunteered somewhere or read something
when i started this project i was not
super familiar with it
a recap of things you need to know today
details different per state in general
there are around 400 000 youth in foster
care on any given day
these are youth ages 0 through 18 or 21
depending on region and circumstances
who are not under their original
parental guardianship
a youth can exit the foster care system
via reunification or adoption or
emancipation
and of course you can read more at these
links
about 50 years ago
a judge in 70s
said you know i don't think i know
enough to make these decisions to make
these decisions about the care of foster
youth
i want somebody to go out and find me
some more data
and the thing that he created grew up to
be the casa organization
casa is a national organization with
many local chapters corresponding to
court regions because the court regions
vary in small but significant ways in
how they want you to do things
volunteers go through
30 hours of training plus
continuing education require they're
sworn in by a judge for a two-year
minimum
and assigned to one youth maybe two if
they're siblings
and they gather information they talk to
everybody involved in the care of the
youth and they file a court report every
six months
informing the court and of course
showing up in court to provide all
relevant information that they can
these volunteers some of them are in law
school but a lot of them are retired
they are very good at what they do
they do not all love paperwork
so we're we are part of that second part
uh how are they funded they each find
their own
uh there are there are grants that they
work to get uh but they each find their
own
what do they do right now and how
the casa volunteer talks to
the youth of course the parents the
health professionals the teachers
everybody they take notes they remind
people they do a lot of phone calls
there
a lot a lot of phone calls
a volunteer has a supervisor the
supervisor is with their parent casa
organization so casa prince george
county maryland costa montgomery
volunteers are unpaid sometimes they get
mileage reimbursements the supervisors
help them get the right format for their
court reports help them remember to
follow up with everyone involved in a
case
not just the youth or the the people who
are easy to reach
um
and of course they attend their the
volunteers attend their ongoing training
the data that we gather is very useful
for
proving that a casa is doing something
useful in particular like you know 300
hours this week type of thing that is
not our purpose that is not what we are
here for that is a
nice accidental byproduct
there are lots of pieces of software
that do something like what we do we are
not trying to compete with them we are
not trying to compete with them our work
is a nice addendum to what they have our
uniqueness is maximum simplicity for the
volunteer
and we're free and we're friendly we
work closely with the casa organization
to implement the changes that they want
and that is why they put up with us
taking their precious time
because we are very responsive to what
they want
volunteers are the heart of what gets
done volunteer retention is extremely
important how do you retain a volunteer
it is
in large part related to their
relationship with their supervisor
we do not want to mess with that
relationship we want to support it we
want to sustain it we want to make it
easier we do not want to replace it we
do not want to make it more distance
that is extremely important
who's we i keep saying we so ruby for
good is an organization
they have a lot of projects not just
casa we we are
i think the coolest but we are
definitely not the only one
uh
some
currently ongoing human essentials
terror stories circulate tool library
shelter assist which is brand new mutual
aid abalone and others they have a whole
website about all the cool things
they've done historically
the purpose of the organization is both
to create software for nonprofits and to
be a friendly place to
do non-profit
contributions growing the tech community
broader than it otherwise would be by
helping people in usually people
who otherwise would bounce off or have a
harder time or have a longer road
by making making it easy and possible to
contribute to software in general
regardless of skill level let me say
that again regardless of skill level
that's a little different than getting a
pull request merge into some projects
that i have not merged pull requests
into
uh ruby for good hosts two-year events
people show up
in person or not in person lately
and pick a project get on boarded
contribute that's cool how did they get
together with casa a former casa
volunteer
is now a software developer and joined
ruby for good how did i get here in 2019
i signed up for a conference naive i
know i checked the box saying would you
like to be a tech lead i did not know
what that box meant i felt confident
thank you always nice to be acknowledged
um
i got assigned to casa that was cool we
did a lot of planning we did a lot of ui
mockups we did a lot of database schema
planning and then 2020 we surprise had a
remote conference with maybe a month of
warning
it went very well
thanks to the flexibility of the
attendees and a lot of spreadsheets and
a lot of zoom breakout rooms and a lot
of hard work so what did we build and
what have we built since then
guided tour go here's our login page
this photo is from casa national
marketing we picked one that only has a
youth in it because
that's what we're here for we don't need
a picture of a volunteer we need a
picture of a youth we are fully
responsive for mobile volunteers can use
it from whatever whatever device they
have wherever they are
and we have an android app which is a
very thin layer over all of this
basically to make it possible to find in
the app store we're working on ios
this is the most important page in the
application
it
it glows when i look at it i know that
to you it's just a web page but when i
look at it it glows uh a case contact is
when the volunteer talks to
somebody related to the care of the
youth the use case the categories and
contact types are fully customizable per
casa and per
youth so if this youth doesn't have a
sibling sibling would not show up in
this list and that is very important to
them because this is meant to be a kind
of checklist
and a personal personalizable system is
something that they don't they don't
believe can be true and we are trying to
make it true
um
contact made means did they pick up the
phone did they answer the door you know
if the volunteer drove an hour to get
there and nobody showed up that's still
working we still want to record it and
it's important to record it so that you
know
hey this is an area which we need to
follow up on
this is the most important field on this
most important page this is notes
notes is
just a text field you can put anything
in it you want and yes that worries me
in production on average this is about
400 words peaking at several thousand
words this is where the majority of the
effort of the volunteers goes this is
where they write down their thoughts and
feelings and concerns and plans and
notes
and we ask them to please not put pii
personally identifiable information in
here because we do not want to hold it
but they can do anything we want and no
i do not audit in production so we are
very protective of this data
so after you've created that case
contact
this is the case details page i just
want to step back for a minute so this
page there's a lot of stuff on this page
there's a lot of buttons on this page
this is maybe 100 to 150 pull requests
and github issues that you're looking at
right here
so in the top left there is a butterfly
i like the butterfly that butterfly is
definitely my fault that means that they
are a transition aged youth so a
teenager
generally somewhere in the 14 and up
range which affects how you want to
treat the case and the training that
different people get
front and center there are the court
orders otherwise known as court mandates
otherwise known as things that the judge
has said you shall do those are very
important and it's important to be
reminded of them on a very regular basis
we want to make them bigger prettier
maybe sparkly we're thinking about it
if you're a designer come talk to me
top right there is that generate report
button for that all important court
report
it downloads in a word format because
word format is the language of the land
[Music]
and
right next to it i swear i'll move on in
a minute there's the emancipation
checklist the emancipation checklist is
very important emancipation means you
have aged out of foster care
it's complicated but anyway
and so the checklist is things like do
you have a driver's license have you
ever had a job do you have a place to
stay when you are no longer being
provided a place to stay important stuff
that it is
good for the volunteer to keep in mind
when they keep track of things and uh
brand new there's a little button for
the supervisor to remind the volunteer
hey how are you doing in there buddy i
love you a lot i haven't heard from you
in a while
in case that that is useful to have it
come from the system instead of from
them
we export data they have a special
button for mileage reports because some
people don't want to edit all of their
own excel files all the time when we
could do it for them in code and then we
have a generalized report with all the
filters we could possibly think of we do
not want to block up their data behind
any type of wall we want to let the
people who should have it have it which
is the admins of the casa so they can
download their reports and talk to their
volunteers and talk to their supervisors
and plan their grant proposals all that
good stuff we have imports oh man
imports
have you ever
tried to import a csv like file
yes
okay we will go into this in great depth
later what we import is
all of the supervisors and volunteers
and cases and the relationships between
them when a casa joins a system of
course they import all 300 or 500 of
their volunteers plus supervisors in
cases cases always outnumber volunteers
unfortunately
and
we have a great ui pattern which we
generated from scratch for ourselves i'm
sure it's in a book somewhere if you
want someone to upload a csv give them a
downloadable csv in the same format that
makes it very easy for them to fill it
out with their own data and give it back
to you
wonderful
when you've imported your volunteers you
can edit them you can activate them
deactivate them assign them to a case or
multiple cases assign them to a
supervisor
our users love our ui i want you to know
that our users love our ui it is simple
it is user friendly there is nothing
there that they do not need
that's pretty cool it's not too flashy
but it is loved
so volunteers why do volunteers
volunteer why do contributors contribute
because we have those namespace
collisions of course
volunteers here or casa volunteers and
contributors are people who do things in
github
just making that clear
lot of our contributors contribute
because they want
a better job or a job or to feel like
they know enough for their current job a
lot of them want to work specifically on
open source software because they
believe that that is a good thing to do
and a lot of them want to meet the kind
of people who want to help other people
and that is pretty great
why do maintainers maintain how do
maintainers maintain what does
maintaining mean for me
my job my not a job is about 80 making
it easy for other people to do work i
love it when other people do work it's
fantastic
i love other people doing work i like
coding i do it for fun i do it for work
when i want extra fun i do it for casa
but that is not the core value that i
provide the core value that i provide is
encouragement and being a safety net
i am
one of the several people hopefully all
of us who say
you can do it
one of the very reassuring things i say
to new contributors is it's okay if your
pull request is really really bad if
it's really really bad i promise not to
merge it and they find that tremendously
reassuring for some reason
and then i say oh we'll improve it
together come to office hours please
just open the pr please just open the pr
um you should ask about that in slack oh
yep that looks like a bug please file
that bug please file that bug
so open source but software as a service
open source that's different that's a
little unusual
some things we have going for us
merging doesn't make it real because i
have merged it does not mean it is
production and that is great
we also don't have a giant continuous
integration matrix we don't have
backwards compatibility issues except
with our own database
and of course we need hosting
software as a service in general a lot
of people work on for work
we are holding someone else's data that
is important we should keep it safe what
you are not holding you cannot drop what
you are not holding you cannot drop
we have stakeholders who are
non-technical they speak a different
language and we need an expert
translator having an expert translator
is very useful usually called a pm maybe
an analyst
sometimes called me
and of course we need to do some some
amount of customer support and we need
uptime we need it to actually be on so
people can use it
our job does not end at publishing a uh
deployable
we have priorities data safety data
safety is always on top do not give
someone's data to anyone other than that
someone and someone on the level of casa
organizations often we want to make the
casa volunteers lives easier
and the lives of casa as a whole
more
more sustainable more efficient and we
want to help our contributors grow their
skills we want to be a healthy place for
people to make their first ever pull
requests if possible that is great that
is a triumph for us
and feel happy about it that part is
also required
and in order to do that we need a
pipeline of work
so what do we do what works for us let's
talk extremely granular nitty gritty
i have a list
this is inspiration this is not a guide
this is not what you should do this is
what we do
first and foremost human impact it is
wonderful that we have a very clear and
simple causal chain between the work
that we do and helping human beings that
you could identify if they were not
anonymous
because we do not keep youth names we
keep youth case numbers which are
different than names in public
a lot of our contributors are already
specifically interested in improving
this particular ecosystem a lot of them
become interested over time
as they learn more about what we do and
the contributors that we have and they
talk to the stakeholders every week
and they hear about our work so how do
we talk to our stakeholders we talk to
them every week
half an hour a week
and they show up again because they like
us and because they want to tell us
about our bugs and so that we can
extract from them ideas for features
that we want to build because we always
need more features that we want to build
we live blog it into slack and then we
pick the highlights into our word
document
our google drive document which has been
open since 2019 it's a weird feeling to
be editing the same document for like
several years
and the the administrators of the costas
talk to each other they cross chatter
during these calls and they love it they
love telling each other their problems
and we love listening to it because it
gives us ideas we send them a weekly
email every time we deploy we deploy
weekly and we always always always cc
the main account cost it ruby for good
on anything so it doesn't get locked in
someone's inbox and nobody has to come
back from vacation to frantic demands
that we need the images that someone
emailed them in october
we have a smart bug reporter that gently
guides non-technical people through
good bug reports got to get that url got
to get that user level got to get that
part of the page
because we want the minimum level of
effort with the maximum return and and
and and we have youtube playlists that's
how cool we are we have youtube
playlists and with walkthroughs of the
website our volunteers really like
watching walkthroughs of seeing people
use the website that is of great value
to them
and that typeform publishes to our
private slack channel because you can
type anything in a type form
and we don't necessarily want to be
public
we have a very strong cadence i'm a very
big believer in cadence and breaks we
have our weekly stakeholders sync we
have our weekly office hours on the same
day so we can go through our notes and
understand what they meant and transform
them into github issues and action items
we have a weekly deploy we skip it for
big holidays we skip it when we're tired
but you never have to work to remember
when it is
and we've got slow times between big
events which is wonderful because you
need to rest sometimes what about those
big events last week was ruby for good
east
in the dc area
people show up now you are friends
they choose a project they onboard we
write pull requests it's pretty great
that was my first in-person event in a
very long time and it was terrifying but
it was wonderful
and we do kind of like project level
deep directions setting think like
development sprints so that's pretty
good we also
are a destination for company offsites
um we are very happy for companies who
want to give back to their community to
come hang out with us for a day or a
week and demolish our backlog
even better they bring their pms and qas
and designers to help replenish our
backlog and set up that future direction
and if your company is interested please
email us we are interested in you right
back
hacktoberfest started today
hacktoberfest is an event which
encourages and rewards open source
software contributions for us it is
great it can be hard on maintainers of
big famous projects
as you can see last year it worked very
well for us and we are already seeing it
work very well for us this year
we have a public calendar that
contributors can subscribe to
and owned by that shared account so it
doesn't go missing if someone's email
becomes unavailable
and of course we've got that invite for
our stakeholders so they know when and
where to show up and where the zoom link
is and we add new stakeholders when we
get them
so that is pretty cool gotta put that
zoom link somewhere
and we have slack everyone has slack we
are part of the ruby for good slack
which is great great for
cross-pollination between projects we
get ideas from them they get ideas from
us
and they provide moderation and invite
management so that we don't have to
thank you
we have an active public channel with
channel reminders for meetings we have a
private channel for maintainers
to discuss maintainer things mostly for
the type 4 and bug report to show up in
and for various people to say hey i
won't be there today which is great and
we have a bot channel which is extremely
noisy as it should be for pull requests
and issues and errors and deploys
it's a good heartbeat for the project
it's a source of memory
uh historical record you're like i saw a
bug on monday i wonder if i can find it
there it is we have continuous
integration it runs all of our tests on
every pull request and on the main
branch on every new pull request merge
it's split into parallel named build
sections which is very convenient to be
able to see what the heck happened in
there
and it runs on github actions as you can
see we use github depend a bot is so
great if you have a project on github
use dependabot it opens pull requests to
upgrade your dependencies so that you
don't get into the situation where you
show up and you need to upgrade
something and then that depends on
something else and then that something
else is broken it keeps you out of that
mess entirely and it is my favorite
we use github project management github
project management
is simple basic but automatable and
we've got those sweet sweet workflow
automations going on
this is one of my favorite power tools
we have automated a great deal of
maintainer emotional labor specifically
when an issue has been assigned to
someone and there has been no report
request or comment for a certain number
of days and now it is you need to remind
somebody in a while after that you need
to unassign it the bot does that for us
in a very nice repeatable way that does
not involve anyone waking up with a
to-do list item and it is fantastic
we use github wiki for our deployment
checklist for our who's who for our
historical record pull request templates
issue templates all that great github
stuff a note on github permissions lock
down your main branch please lock down
your main branch nobody should be able
to force push to it if you really need
to for reasons which we will not discuss
here remove the permission do it and
then put the permission back
we are
casa is a little strange with branches
we prefer branches to forks where
possible because
if there is a branch
and that branch is
ready to merge except for that one
little thing then the maintainer can go
in there and do that one little thing
and merge it instead of waiting for that
one little thing to get done and then
merging it or
there's many alternatives but this is
the one that is most convenient for us
but forks are more educational because
that is how the world works now so some
of each git is one of git and github or
one of the harder parts for new
contributors getting started in open
source and it always has been even
though it's much easier now
so just trying to make it easier where
we can
we use issue templates issue templates
are great you can tell i've been here
because of all those sparkly emoji
building a template is an art these are
the best pieces of many other excellent
artifacts
we want the minimum that will make for
better user contributions and
while still guiding our users to do what
we need them to do
we deploy every week heck yeah
uh a merge pull request auto deploys to
qa
and then there's a button to manually
apply to staging if you have permission
to see the button and a button to
manually vote cloud and we have a deploy
checklist
where we check on our database backups
and check on our email health gotta make
sure that bounce rate isn't too high
we use roku kron for those monday
morning emails to the supervisors like
hey here's everything your volunteers
have done this week and we have code we
have lots and lots of code we've got so
much code
we have a lot of tests a lot more than
half our code is tests tests are very
important they are our only defense
against ourselves
and a pull request without sufficient
testing might get merged but we will
file a chore to add more testing to it
maybe to refactor something if we want
to
to reduce uh complexity we try to keep
the absolute minimum of javascript we
are a mostly server-side rendered
application
but we do have some everyone has some it
just creeps in around the edges it's
wonderful
we have a readme the readme is very
important that's how new contributors
experience your project that's how they
get used to what you're doing our readme
is very successful because many people
have successfully gotten set up because
of it
that is that is the criteria for
dependencies we try to stay basic and
stay picky every dependency is a
liability that can come back and bite
you on the other hand you don't want to
write your authentication and
authorization yourself we want the best
of both worlds it makes it makes life
sad sometimes so to want the best of
everything but we get it done
we have picked the least configurable
winter we could find thank you standard
rb
we have a docker development environment
which not everyone uses but it runs in
ci so we do not break it again
and of course we've got that thin
android app we have realistic seed data
which is very cool because when you run
locally you need to fill in that seed
data so that you can see what the
application really looks like you don't
want to have to do that by hand you want
to just be able to blow your data space
away reseed and be good to go
and we populate that c data a larger
form of it in staging and qa so that our
users can look at it and not be
distracted by invalid data when they're
trying to decide whether or not they
like a particular feature
oh this is the good stuff um
this is controversial you will not like
it some of you
we merge pull requests very fast where
possible fast merging increases
contributor stickiness we need
contributor stickiness people stick
around because they feel that their work
is valued
we have a cultural expectation that a
maintainer
approves a pull request and then
immediately merges it doesn't wait for
someone to merge their own pull request
that's a little weird if there's notes
like oh could you refactor this method
could you factor this test could you add
this test we ask that the contributor
add them in a follow-up pull request
and we find that that
produces a large number of follow-up
pull requests containing the desired
changes it works very well for us we
originally started this to minimize
merge conflicts during on-site events
where we had a very high volume and we
kept going because we like the way it
feels
by the way this is not all ruby for good
projects this is just us we're weird
that's good that's fine
we can do this because merging deploys
but not product not project to
production we get that safety net
we've got all those tests love those
tests
tests are my favorite
and community last our community is
great
we don't need to
negotiate with firoku for server time
that gets handled
and
if we have a an urgent bug or an urgent
feature
then i can just post in general and be
like send help
and help actually shows up i have a lot
of trust in this because we have used it
several times and it worked i highly
recommend having a large group of people
who can show up and fix your bugs
summarize
there are things we want to keep doing
because they're working for us we want
to be people at each other we want to be
chill sometimes we like group events we
like powerful tools
we want to deploy often but carefully
and be a little paranoid about our
dependencies and merge pull requests as
fast as we can
all right
hard things things that give us trouble
i have a list
there's always a list
these are not your problems these are
our problems you probably also have
these problems you may not know about
your problems we always need more issues
unlike many open source projects our
issues mostly do not come from
contributors they mostly come from
stakeholders
filtered through maintainers
because stakeholders speak a different
language that does not translate exactly
into github issues
and that translation takes work
in a regular week we'll go through two
or ten github issues during one of our
big events we will go through our entire
150 issue backlog within the week which
is great but also a problem this is a
great problem to have but it is still a
problem that we have
because writing issues takes effort and
we have people who do that as their main
contribution people who don't write code
people who just write issues and that is
fantastic and we love them
when i read an issue for myself it says
fix the button on the edit page
which edit page which button
which fix is there a button did there
used to be a button
write the issues for the people that you
want to solve them
i highly recommend not writing issues
for yourself unless you want yourself to
be the only one who will solve them
which does not work very well
another thing that we have problems with
is system edges import i told you would
come back to import specifically with
table-based data
the volunteers cases supervisors and the
linkages between them those
cross-references are what really gets
you
if you're importing data and there's a
duplicate unique key which in this case
would be an email do you override the
data do you keep the old data do you
show an error and not do anything until
the user resolves it
if there's two rows that are the same do
you de-duplicate them what if they're
different same problem
if row one and row two row two depends
on one but row one fails what do you do
with row two do you try to import it
like halfway
that's what we do because that's what
our users want
but that might not be what you should do
and that was not immediately obvious
that should be what we do
and of course how do you display per row
errors for a spreadsheet with hundreds
of errors it will take up your entire
web page and nobody will read it we give
you a downloadable csv with an error per
line of the original upload so that you
can edit them as needed as possible
[Music]
i don't know if you care but i can talk
about this indefinitely what else system
edges export word is hard did you know
that word documents are difficult we use
user supplied word templates and fill
them with user supply data and we want
them to look nice
so we already know we have an impossible
problem that's good
and then we slice and dice that data
based on like date ranges and we're just
doomed um but it is currently working
very well and we tune it a little bit
for each new court report template as we
find new new and exciting bugs we are
currently using sablon which is
not the most popular rubygem for it so
kind of contradicting our previous
statement but it works very very good
for the kind of thing that we need to do
what else memory memory is hard all
projects have this problem
i don't think that anyone can fix this
problem
but it's what we have so by memory i
mean hey why did we do that hey why is
this here
things that you already know the
collective you but that the singular you
does not know things that we know that i
do not know you can search slack history
you can search github issues you can
search the wiki you can search the
meeting docs we have architectural
decision records and of course we have
verbal history which is to say go ask
somebody and it is never ever enough
and all projects have this and i don't
really think we can fix this
but
anyway it's on the list
testing testing is in some ways an art
how do you teach good testing especially
when everyone disagrees about what good
testing is good testing is a skill it is
hard to put in acceptance criteria
you can talk about code coverage but
code coverage is not sufficient
style is also important
coverage doesn't even mean that you're
fully covered what about flaky tests
what about testing at the wrong level
unit versus system tests
so i think
we lean hard on erb how do you test erb
in like a correct and sufficient manner
stuff like that
and then finally missing contributor
feedback
some people show up one time and then
leave and then we never hear from them
again and yes this bothers me because we
will never know what happened was it me
was it us was it
you know they just had the wrong bagel
like we will never know
um some other people leave the project
in the best way by getting a new job
that they like a lot
probably partially from connections and
encouragement and knowledge that we
contributed to that's pretty great we
can just measure the number and
contribution lifespan of contributors
send out surveys read the responses if
we get any
and just work on it that way
so to summarize
backlogs are hard system edges that's
supposed to be a dragon here be dragons
future archaeology
testing testing the art testing the
science and getting feedback from
contributors
contributors encourage contributors
become strong contributors
most of our contributors come in because
a friend told them that we're the kind
of project that will let them work that
will help them work contributors bring
energy they can grow knowledge they
don't need to bring the knowledge they
will grow the knowledge and they can
spend their extra time and energy on
boarding more contributors for us
and uh pitching us to their friends
hint hint hint
how do you encourage someone
uh that's a hard question with an easy
answer say the words you can do it you
got this that idea sounds good please do
it
that's that is the first easiest and
best step
a note on purpose what is your project's
purpose your project has a purpose
that's the easy one
what are your contributors purposes what
do they want out of contributing to your
project is it fame is it money is it
connections
you don't necessarily need to solve
whatever problem or solution that is but
knowing
knowing what the goal is is helpful what
are your users purposes
our users do their purpose is not to use
our software their purpose is to get
what they need to do done and if we are
useful in that
occasion then that will work out for us
and if it isn't then it won't
and last what is your purpose as a
maintainer what do you want to get out
of this what do you think the goal is
recap of technical tips when you want
users to upload a spreadsheet provide a
downloadable sample spreadsheet
use github workflows to automate
emotional labor around ticket management
pull requests that deployed cleanly
individually may not deploy cleanly
together especially if they are editing
the same table
and
word documents are hard word document
save edit history which is not visible
in word but is visible
directly in
libreoffice or other tools check for
sensitive info before attaching one to a
github issue
and after you have failed that then
delete it send apologetic emails and
file a takedown request for your own
project pull request with github thank
you github
um to recap safety nets are great
multi-level safety nets multiple
maintainers a deployment pipeline lots
of tests a backing organization if you
can land one
uh multiple purposes serving our
stakeholders growing our contributors
having a strong cadence that's
impossible to forget but easy to skip
during the slow times and sustainable
maintainership requires rest
oh god uh so
help we would like your help please send
help the thing that i want the most the
most the most that may not be available
is more casa regional organizations we
are at 4 ish out of over 900 we've got
space come on we're uh we're free and
we're friendly if you happen to know
someone who knows someone who would like
to trial a free tool
we are happy to be those people
we also really like pms and qas and
designers to come and tell us
their opinions and their thoughts
and pull requests pull requests or the
bread and butter especially that testing
and refactoring heck yeah
and thanks thanks to all of the the many
many people who make this happen and
many more that do not have space here
and questions
do we have an extra minute
we do case numbers case numbers have
meaningful formats that vary per court
region
and so they start with letters like cena
and tpr a child in need of assistance
and determination of parental rights and
then that first number is the year that
you enter the court system and then that
second number is the year
is the the number youth you are within
the year
that's uh you get collisions between
court organizations and that affects how
you build your urls because you know
you're going to have collisions if you
use useful data namespaces so you need
an extra name space
common question what is fictive kin
fictive kin is non-blood relations
and i see that we are at time and i
should probably stop
working with word documents watch out
for those rendering issues i will not
tell you about every gem maintainer
selection is hard
we would like to do something slightly
different it is informal you do a lot of
work you get a message you get
permissions you do a lot more work and
then optional fade away we would like to
we would like to invite people to be
maintainers before they've done all of
you know a great deal of hard work so
that you can grow into the role as other
people have
and finally our qa pipeline or our
deployment pipeline which is small and
simple and beautiful and saves us so
much trouble qa to staging to production
looks a little bit like jenkins if you
squint
and it is my favorite and that is all
[Applause]
[Music]
you